hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy
and the president and founder of an
educational consulting company called
reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well in
addition to good humor
or wit and friendliness which are two
social virtues that that
arise talks about and discusses in the
nick of mccain ethics and also to a
lesser extent in the eudaimian ethics
there's another one that he says governs
social interactions between human beings
and he thinks that this is something
important for a person to possess
this is a very interesting and almost
unique contribution on his part
to virtue ethics
at least up until his time afterwards it
becomes something much discussed
and that is being truthful not truthful
in just
any sense whatsoever saying business
dealings that would actually fall under
justice aristotle says so some of
honesty
or truthfulness is a matter of other
virtues
that courage might be required as well
we've seen that in friendliness
that involves telling the truth to
friends as well telling them that the
activities that they're engaged in
if they're harmful or shameful are
actually such and that they shouldn't be
doing so
now this has to do with
truth about one's own self conveyed
in acts and in speeches in
one's way of life in one's relationships
and as with all the other virtues and
vices it's possible to go too far
it's possible to be lacking the
excess in this case is
boastfulness or being a braggart
these days we would call it inflating
your qualities
there was a very interesting discussion
a while ago in which i
participated a bit about whether one
should be a self-promoter
or not and i'll touch on that at the end
a lot of times we think of people being
self-promoting is falling over here
on the other side of vice or deficiency
we have
those who engage in self-deprecation
the greek word for that is actually
irony so
socrates is a representative of the
ironic
attitude towards things and now irony
can mean something more where
you're saying something and you're
trying to lead the interlocutor to
realize something about themselves
you know for example when he says to
many of his interlockers
well you know you obviously know all
about that could you enlighten me
but there's also a bit of uh
putting the self down involved in that
well i don't really know about anything
so why don't you enlighten me
it's kind of a um at least in socrates
part
it's kind of a pretense in many cases
and and many people
felt that he was sort of not
giving them the straight story and they
would say well you know come out and
actually say what you mean and so i
just prefer to you know engage in this
question and dialogue and stuff like
that
aristotle says that a lot of people who
do that are
actually doing something that's that's
vicious he thinks that this
vice is not as bad as this vice and that
actually the virtue
is going to steer over this way
oftentimes we look at people like this
and we say that while they're being
humble they are
they're fitting in well with other
people by not
pushing their own qualities their own
achievements by not making a big
big show of themselves people like this
are a bit easier to get along with
than people like this although this
could go too far
if you think aristotle hasn't talk about
this so much
but this is a very common problem in our
society people who
can't take a compliment who don't know
what to do
with a compliment who get all flustered
and then have to deny
what they're being complimented about
that that's a problem
you know not being able to take
criticism is one problem not being able
to take praise
is another problem and that would fall
over over here
by the way people over here are going to
be very bad about taking criticism
so here's what's really interesting
about this
aristotle says that
the truthful person is a lover of truth
feel alethea they they love truth
and that means loving something
outside of oneself that puts the self
into
context that's what allows the truthful
person to actually
be truthful about themselves they
they prefer to be
in the truth than to think false things
about themselves
so when they do something wrong or
really not up to standards
they are okay not with having done that
but with it being said that that's the
case
without being represented they are able
to take criticism
because they actually do take criticism
for what it
what it means the truth in it
it doesn't mean that they're gonna
they're gonna accept any sort of
criticism off-base criticism they're
probably not gonna accept that
this person over here is a lover of
falsehood
they love a false inflated
image of themselves that they want to
hold up
in front of other people and also
for themselves
aristotle says something really
interesting he says
those who boast for the sake of
reputation pretend to possess such
qualities as they're crazy
as an admired those who possess
those who do so for profit pretend to
accomplishments that are useful to their
fellows and can be counterfeited without
detection
for instance where he says something
really funny proficiency in prophecy
anybody can claim to be a prophet or a
fortune teller or
a success guru or an internet crew or
all sorts of unverifiable things and
then he says two other things
or philosophy or medicine medicine was
was kind of touch and go at that time
and aerosol speaking from experience his
dad was a doctor
and aristotle knew a lot about the
medical arts that were existing at that
time and about the people who were
claiming to have
you know uh skill and the people who
actually did have them
but he also says that about philosophy
isn't that funny that
there's quite a few people who are
braggarts about philosophy
and they they do so precisely because
it's kind of hard to tell who really is
good and
who isn't good who has the qualities
so the lover of truth locates themselves
in truth the lover of falsehood
actually prefers something what is the
the person who's self-deprecating
prefer they may prefer to be
unbothered by other people there are
some cultures in which it's very smart
to
not make a big deal out of yourself
some societies you know you're the
outside of your house
you won't really keep it up very well
but the inside will be very beautiful
because you don't want people from the
outside thinking that you're rich
or well off because they might rob you
or try to tax you
or things like that there's things like
that that happen in organizations
if you know that you're not going to be
rewarded for actually displaying
initiative
or using talents that they haven't you
know yet tapped
don't show them off you know that might
actually be more
prudence than being self-deprecating in
that case
the self-deprecating person pretends not
to have the qualities the good qualities
that they actually have
or they downplay them they they say um
yeah i know i scored a 99 on the exam
but i was lucky
uh things worked out for me that day i i
had enough time
on my hands to really study and i didn't
have other exams going on so
so it was easier for me than for other
people you see a lot of people doing
this with their achievements aristotle
seems to think
that no if you are really sincere
about yourself with other people it is
okay
to to as we say brag on yourself but not
bragging on yourself in a false sense if
you've actually done something good
you should in fact tell yourself i have
done something good
if you have a track record of success
you should actually tell yourself that
on the other hand
if you don't have a track record of
success with something then don't
pretend like you do
over here we have a person who pretends
to have
qualities and achievements that they
don't possess or that are lesser and
it's interesting to see
how people will often times take a
lesser achievement and then blow it up
into a bigger achievement
so here's where we get to something
really interesting to think about
and this is very timely right now we're
in a very tough economy
every time i apply for a job there's 500
applicants at least
for for that position unless it's some
very very you know low grade
thing that almost nobody would want but
we're all scrabbling for anyway
do you inflate your accomplishments
in your cover letter do you make
implicit promises about what you can do
and what you can't do do you puff
up your your contacts and say that you
know people
who you really don't know but
they're they're you know acquaintances
of yours
these are the sorts of things that
happen in cover letters
and resumes in interviews there's an
awful lot of that going on once you have
a job
how do you rightly call your
achievements
what you've accomplished the hard work
that you've put in
the skills that you've developed how do
you rightly
call them to the attention of your
superiors your co-workers
do you compete for teacher of the year
award or employee of the month
do you ask for the promotion this is
all a matter of virtues and vices
um the truthful person the person is
really truthful about themselves the one
thing they have going for them
is the fact that they actually remain
within the bounds of truth
so it's always easier to tell the the
truth than to stick with a lie
over the long haul unless you're in a
terrorist society you know which is just
based on lies
because the truth actually does conform
to something real
and sooner or
this this person later fundamentally
motivated by
an appreciation for truth they think
that truth is in a certain
sense more encompassing more important
than their own self-image
for these other people something else is
more important
and when you place something else higher
on the scale than truth
you're really towing a dangerous line
and now aristotle doesn't develop this
as far as he
could the passages are fairly short
where he's discussing this
this is a very rich topic
that could be explored in much greater
detail